alors moi je pense ap
énormément
on est vrai métier ça va
chose eux
j'ai appris des choses simples en mieux
moi ya 200 ans on nous appelle des
bouffons donc moins on va garder un peu
à la tête froide et pour penser
différemment j'ai commencé à aller dans
les toilettes handicapés tout de suite
permettra d' un peu différent dont je
suis demandé pendant fou je mange je
remercie qui m'a appelé pour me demander
si je voulais venir m'a demandé ma lundi
voilà le but c'est penser différemment
expliqué pourquoi je vous dis mais
comment je vais commencer ça comment je
vais leur dire comment comment je vais
leur expliquer puis il m'est arrivé un
truc la semaine dernière qui est tout à
fait parlons j'écris des livres et il ya
une dame c'est bien pour 6 enfin je
signe donc je dédicace les livres à des
lecteurs et des lectrices et puis la
dalle me dit c'est merveilleux vous
écrivez c'est super mais vous faites
quoi comme métier chebah j'écris oui
mais c'est quoi votre métier vous savez
un coin et j'ai pas su quoi répondre
parce que ça m'a vraiment fait rire et
ça me renvoie ça me renvoie à hautem
aujourd'hui on développe
moi j'ai pas de jets pas de fonctions
vitales
j'adorais le discours de la dernière
personne qui est passé parce que c'est
hyper fondamentale
moi mon métier c'est de divertir et à la
limite de faire penser un petit peu
différemment alors je suis atterré parce
que dans le monde d'aujourd'hui on vous
explique comment il faut penser et on
vous dit très tôt on vous demande quel
métier vous voulez faire en ondes en
cinquième en demandant le quatrième on
demande en troisième puis on selon vous
devez faire des choix et tout moi saison
à ceux dont je voulais des cosmonautes
j'ai eu deux au mato bat donc j'ai ce
mouvement et puis
voilà donc on évolue moi j'ai une fille
de 16 ans aujourd'hui et elle en
première es et même bip apache est
vraiment pas ce que je vais faire je dis
merci
ouf ouf parce que le métier que je fais
donc faire des films écrire des
bulletins c'est juste pensée et penser
autrement
pour moi ça revient juste à penser par
soi même c'est à dire il ya énormément
de choses qui nous font peur tout ce qui
tout ce qui sort de la norme tout ce qui
est différent et pendant des années
quand on est jeune quand on est ado
quand j'étais jeune je voulais
absolument pas être différent des autres
je voulais écouter les mêmes musiques
noter les mène dans ce groupe sur le sac
histoire de me fondre dans la masse et
avoir avoir l'air d'être comme tout le
monde
finalement c'est ce qu'il ya de pierre
j'entendais des gens tout à l'heure en
disant bon il faut qu'on change le monde
non non le monde passait de préserver
ses les gens qu'il faut changer le monde
ça serait bien si on changeait pas trop
le but c'est nous changer alors
pour tous ceux qui ont eu des copines et
des copains dans leur vie et qui ont eu
des échecs qui se sont fait larguer j'en
fais partie on ne change pas beaucoup
on évolue mais ça c'est déjà super bien
et donc j'ai commencé au fur et à mesure
au fur et à mesure des années à venir
vers la différence main au lieu d'être
un handicap c'est juste une richesse et
on est tous différent vous êtes il ya
combien une deux trois générations on a
des origines différentes mais prenons
les étudiants qui sont ici ils sont de
la même génération on va pas dire que ce
sont des mêmes milieux sociaux mais il
doit y avoir une sorte de généralités et
y en a pas un qui cette semaine de la
même manière pourtant vous parlez tous
la même langue
vous avez tous une éducation différente
des événements des expériences
différentes
vous rencontrez des gens différents vous
êtes marquée par des choses différentes
donc vous êtes différent et la penser
autrement
c'est juste penser par soi même et mon
métier c'est ça mon métier c'est d'aller
juste penser par moi même et essayer de
faire partager et je trouve ça assez
dément pas ce que j'avais une une vision
assez pas pauvre mais ridicule du métier
que je fais parce que nous et faire
faire des films ou et faire des films
mois tous les sims et l'impression que
je garde en tête et tout ils sont
tellement énormes mais tellement gros
que je me sens pas à la hauteur de ça
mais je vis mais finalement on feu on
m'a dit y'a pas longtemps que
l'industrie du divertissement c'était la
première au monde
au fait le double de chiffres que
l'industrie automobile
donc respect et le visuel c'est génial
parce que finalement on sert un truc est
en fait d'une manière assez simple sans
avoir fait des études et les rock
machine juste maîtrise de lettres mais
on a
difficilement on a l'occasion d'aller
juste passer une ou deux idées aux gens
alors des fois c'est pas toujours super
intelligent ce qu'on pense à moi quand
je suis sorti star wars à 9 ans j'essaie
de faire bouger tous les autres jeux
couverts les regardons j'essaye encore
ça marche toujours pas mais j'y crois et
je suis finalement arrivé à arriver un
juste donné deux trois idées arriver à
faire en sorte que ça reste en tête
arriver à faire en sorte que vous
reteniez peut-être un mot un son une
émotion une émotion sur les différences
à un moment dans un film je pourrais en
citer des tonnes des moments dramatiques
des moments drôles mais juste avoir le
sentiment de pouvoir diffuser une idée
et bien voilà j'ai pensé ça et je vous
fais partager ça et ça c'est une chance
qui est délirante pour faire un peu
attention finalement à ce qu'on dit et
lun on revient à penser jusque là se
dire ok les uns font que genton ce qu'on
me dit les gérera des généralités de
jean temps j'entends les parler de
l'afrique tout à l'heure c'est génial
parce que l'afrique soit macho fait peur
je fais des bronzes 1,7 mais tout est
régi on est régi par des peurs la peur
ça vous empêche ça vous empêche le de
réfléchir ça vous empêche de penser par
vous même y apparaissent pas une
solution ou de quoi que ce soit c'est
petit à petit de pas avoir peur penser
c'est ne pas avoir peur alors je vous
parle là mais je vais un gros concert
quand j'avais 20 ans et puis je suis
resté deux ans dans une bulle en
plastique à l'institut curie et ce n'est
pas que j'avais peur est alors par
miracle le sort de ceux de ce centre un
mirage pas croyant mais
grâce aux médecins je me sors de ce
cancer et puis je me dit est ce que je
vais faire je faisais plus de lettres
époux donc j'ai commencé à enseigner
bon j'ai vu ce que je faisais des mots
mais je me dis faut que j'arrête tout de
suite pour leur laisser une chance
et puis en fait la seule chose que j'aie
arriver à ça les fait rire un peu et je
dis bon ce que j'écris finalement ça les
fait rire ça les intéresse la mer drom
jour le raconte les choses ça les
intéresse donc j'ai commencé à faire ça
j'ai créé depuis très longtemps depuis
jamais l'âge de 11 ans j'écrivais mal je
le savais pas mais j'y vais et j'ai
commencé à bien mon jeu va aller
présenter ça et puis j'ai commencé à les
voir des boîtes de prod on nous envoie
là je vous faire ça et j'ai eu des non
non non non non par tour et filles je
partis aux états unis et puis j'ai
présenté voilà juste une chose et puis
j'ai gagné un prix et le titre mais de
l'esprit s'appelle ronde masseron basse
et scénariste vol au-dessus d'un nid de
coucou redman un tueur des petits chine
qui osaient pas vu l ça mec assez génial
et puis millau vient de remettre le prix
film est écrit vraiment très très très
mal j'avais 26 ans et le noir ça
commence bien
il fait mais pas des bonnes idées alors
je vais donner des clés parce qu'on
n'apprend pas aux gens et créé on
devient écrit en écrivant mes méthodes
et bonnes idées et dernier créa
c'est juste le contenant l'essentiel ces
contenus donc je vais te donner des clés
et il m'a donné des clés déclic janssen
aujourd'hui on conçoit internationale
mais il m'a vraiment pendant un an et
demi d'études et merde je tu
viens tu bosses avec moi tous les jours
tu trouve un boulot tu sais tu à los
angeles
tu fais ce que tu veux alors j'ai fait
des pizzas je pense que j'ai dû tuer une
bonne vingtaine de personnes gs pas
moins les parents sont morts mais mais
bon voilà je pense que j'étais dégoûté
de la pizza pas mal de gens mais je me
suis débrouillé et il m'a vraiment
appris des choses et peut être bien et
m'a dit au bout d'un an on me dit c'est
bon maintenant je me débrouille et je
suis allé voir je suis allé voir je suis
allé voir les gens chez aller voir les
gens et puis je me suis engagé dans une
boîte s'appelle dreamworks et puis et
puis on était il fallait donner des
idées nouvelles et si au bout de deux
semaines les idées n'était pas la bonne
je voudrais pas gardez vous êtes viré au
bout de deux semaines
je suis resté sept ans et puis j'ai
commencé et puis je me suis retrouvé au
milieu de gens qui jugeait pas qu'ils
entendaient juste les idées et puis
j'avais voilà j'avais 31 ans et je me
suis retrouvé à dialoguer le premier
shrek avec deux monstres qui avait
trente ou quarante ans de plus que moi
qui étais des braises auteurs qui
avaient déposé des métiers crise est
bien et et puis cette fille les choses
sont venues et jeu
mais finalement allé chercher juste la
différence allait se faire confiance pas
avoir peur ça donne une clé cette clé c
c'est l'ignorance
plus vous avez conscience que vous êtes
ignorant plus vous avez envie
d'apprendre des choses et plus vous
mettez à penser aux choses et il ya pire
que telle ignorance il ya croire qu'on
sait croire qu'on sait les certitudes du
coc horrible et vous êtes entouré de
gens qui ont des certitudes qui croît
pour vous qui vous dise ce qu'il faut
faire
tous disent comment il faut le faire où
il faut aller quel métier il faut faire
à 16 ans à 14 ans à 15 ans à 17 ans
alors des fois ils ont raison je dis pas
que c'est une généralité mais mettez
vous en pensez par vous même faites vous
et 10 est allé chercher les informations
et les recevait pas à les recouper les
informations qu'on vous donne allez vous
renseigner allez-vous rencontrer les
gens moi tout ce que j'ai fait en allant
rencontrer des gens je leur ai posé la
question j'ai demandé et le fus perd du
temps j'ai eu oui comme réponses oui
j'ai demandé des choses et je les ai eus
après faut travailler il faut bosser
commandant faut pour sortir ainsi nous
c'est ça commence par non c'est non
c'est non c'est non c'est non c'est non
jusqu'à ce que le film sorte
et là c'est oui les bouquins c'est
pareil moi je sais pas ce que je fais
plein de fautes d'orthographe c'est
honteux et j'étais prof de français
j'aperçus que les ferments ma mère
j'avais 15 à 20 heures en orthographe
mais est-ce parce que vous quand j'écris
j'entends ce que je dis donc je le
regarde pas et comme je tape mal au
clavier je regarde mon clavier quand je
table je regarde pas le résultat
donc faute d'orthographe mais j'ai
appris que emile ouais super comparaison
il s'est plaint de fautes d'orthographe
pourquoi super rallongé et en enfonçant
peut-être fini on travaille on fait de
moins en moins mais encore une fois je
faisais pas les choses parce que j'en
avais peur et et ses délires on sait
juste pas avoir peur d'avoir peur de se
planter par ma peur de se tromper à 20h
ne pas savoir oser aller vers ce que
vous voulez
moi ma fille mon fils j'ai un fils qui
en licence il sait toujours pas ce qu'il
veut faire c'est pas grave tu avances et
20 verse une plaie va faire se passionne
c'est là où tu sois meilleur que tout le
monde c'est là que tu seras n'y a pas de
compétition mais c'est là au moins tu
perdras pas ton temps puisque le ton
dans a très très peu donc pas voir faire
des choses pas avoir peur des choses et
j'ai tourné ainsi de l'année dernière
sept mois avant de tourner le film
maintenant que j'ai un cancer je dois
commencer la préparation deuxième cancer
donc je dis mon commencer la préparation
du film que je vais tourner en ukraine
ans un beau film c'est avec jean reno
universal tout ça et puis là on dit le 8
décembre à un cancer de la gorge pour ça
que j'essaie de voix un prix buzaré du
poids parce que j'ai un peu ça ça c'est
joli et puis et puis comme dit mon
bateau père et moi je pensais que
c'était une heure et demie l'opération
dans ces 9 heures ouais enfin morceaux
de bras ici pour l'étape retour on
enlève la gorge ont failli ne jamais
fumer jamais mur de l'eau du manga un
peu du quotidien
la procession est jamais fumé et et non
mais l'opération 9 heures
d'opération chez mr devons alors combien
de temps depuis un hôpital derrière
quinze jours je fais pas possible à la
prépa du film et où je peux pas t'en dis
mais si tu es obligé tous un don bon
alors se débrouillent tous ils font les
9 heures d'opération je me réveille mais
ça s'est bien passé ont fait treize
jours d'hôpital motors et je me foutais
tellement de ce que j'avais par
inconscience
à part un des sens mais parce que il ya
une chose que j'avais envie de faire
derrière et c'était de faire le film et
moi peur c'était pas faire le film et du
coup je n'avais pas peur de la maladie
mais je voulais absolument
j'avais un objectif derrière et je me
suis retrouvée est une nouveau ses
charmes j'avais du mal je pouvais
prendre en manger je vais juste boire
j'ai une très que demi pendant huit
jours c'est long terme et j'avais la
voix de rage en eau des pins c'est super
et et je me suis retrouvé sur le gâteau
et à préparer mon film pendant trois
semaines un mois avant de commencer à
tourner en plein hiver et tous et et
j'étais heureux
j'étais super heureux j'allais tourner
j'allais commencer la radio chimio la
radio a lâché llosa ce concept deux mois
plus tard serait dû au bout de trois
semaines mais le tournage durer deux
mois donc je n'ai pas le choix
mais j'avais peur je savais
saleh allait bien parce que je savais ce
que j'avais envie de faire plus j'étais
heureux de le faire et j'avais choisi de
le faire alors c'est pas penser
autrement on sait pas c'est pas c'est
juste pensé c'est juste avoir le dorat
se donner le droit pas avoir peur ne
jamais avoir peur ça vous donnera toute
la volonté du monde ça vous fera faire
des choix
des fois les mauvais des fois des monts
je me suis trompé plein de fois plus
tomber j'ai appris j'ai refait voilà
c'est juste ça donc est il pas peur
aller au bout si vous voulez faire
voilà c'est tout ce que j'ai à vous dire
ce soir merci au revoir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]